the webb telescope dazzled the world
with its first batch of images so wired
turned to the one science guy that can
make it all make sense we're taking
pictures of these objects with
astonishing precision
it's like
whoa
if you could somehow be there with your
spacesuit looking out you wouldn't see
any of these things the image was taken
in infrared wavelengths what we also
call heat and so this instrument can
detect all these objects in the infrared
and then we here on earth take those
data and shift it so that it's visible
to our eye the universe is accelerating
apart where the cool thing is the
farther away something is and the faster
it's moving the redder it is and so
they'll use red light for that the near
objects
are closer to the color of chosen for
the central object in this image so
those things that are about the same
distance are blue so a big takeaway is
that these images are enhanced
color-coded basically photoshopped by
nasa artists based on infrared data but
what exactly is being depicted in this
image
you're looking at a stellar nursery
where stars are being born our sun spins
these stars are all spinning that's why
here we are in the solar system with
spinning planets going around a spinning
star all orbiting or moving around the
center of the galaxy it's amazing why is
everything spinning when the mutual
gravity of these particles brings them
together their unevenness often resolve
themselves into a disk and then in the
center of the disk often resolves into
a star where you get a sphere and from
the birth of a star we move on to an
image that depicts a star near the end
of its existence this ring
that has this wonderful name the
southern ring people in the southern
hemisphere of earth astronomers can
observe this but never seen it this
close this is the star that's exploded
that's supernovaed these supernovae are
what creates all the elements that you
and i are made of and so we're looking
at the process that creates life and as
carl sagan would remark since we are
made of the elements of these exploded
stars you and i
are one way the universe knows itself
like dude and in the center is a white
dwarf it's a star that's thrown out most
of its material but is now its gravity
has crushed it down where it's glowing
in
white light so when they look closer
they found out there were two objects
moving around each other it's like if
you've ever been on roller skates or ice
skates you go toward each other and then
grab arms and you go like that so that's
what's happening here
one of the most detailed images of the
bunch depicts a celestial feature
scientists are now gathering information
from the black hole that seems to be
photobombing this black hole in
particular is massive how massive is it
light cannot escape but you can infer
that there's one in there by looking at
the pattern of the light that does get
around it from stars behind it and
nearby stars and so these scientists
right now are looking at this gas cloud
near a black hole and inferring what
elements are in it iron argon neon
sulfur and then the dream everybody is
to look for a planet and then to look
closely at the atmosphere of that planet
but how can we actually spot something
as tiny as a planet that's thousands of
light years away let alone know what
gases and elements it contains the stars
of a certain brightness when the planet
passes between us and the star the
brightness goes down when it gets back
on the far side of the star the
brightness goes up again and it does it
regularly that's the key the planet's
orbiting it does it regularly and that
helps you infer that the dimming and
brightening of the star is because the
planet's going around it looking even
more closely around this you'll get an
ability to look through the atmosphere
with the light from the star behind it
and then looking at the spectra what
wavelengths of light make it through
that atmosphere you're able to infer
what the atmosphere is made of if you're
looking for adventure you can isolate
different gases water vapor oxygen
nitrogen you can shine light through the
gas and some wavelengths will be
absorbed some will pass right through
and this telescope is so sensitive that
you can infer the composition of the
atmosphere so what did they find while
looking at planet wasp 96b which is more
than a thousand light years away so in
this image they found water vapor now
water is very common in our solar system
so it's reasonable that it's common
elsewhere and it's reasonable then you
would have the same sort of processes on
a distant planet and so what everybody
wants to find
is methane
if you found natural gas it might mean
that there's living things producing it
whoa because the main source of methane
here on earth is living things bacteria
so if we find a star with a planet with
an atmosphere that has methane we might
infer that there was life out there
which would change everything it would
change the way you and i feel about
being alive because all of us have
wondered where we all came from are we
alone in the cosmos or is there some
other living thing out there with its
own james webb space telescope looking
at us trying to answer the same question
the discoveries that are be made in the
coming weeks and months and years will
be astonishing and i say all the time my
grandparents didn't know there was
relativity it wouldn't surprise me if in
the next 10 or 30 years there's some
discovery about dark energy and how
these things interact that will change
everything that wouldn't surprise me